tell me about why you don't like why you
exactly I read the pilot episode on a
flight and as soon as I landed I called
everybody and I was like I don't care if
I'm on the show or not I need to know
when it's gonna be going to air because
I have to watch it I need to know what
happens next and when I feel that
passion about a show I mean it's amazing
to then be able to participate on it and
be on it so yeah I was excited I got to
see two episodes okay but we I mean the
chemistry between pen and you I mean a
little scary it is a little scary and I
mean just the dynamic of almost a three
of them it's kind of like a love
triangle if he was so it was a it was
really fun to be able to play that not
only is she the queen bee and slightly
on the meaner side but her relationship
with Joe was really really fun to play
but I loved those exchanges peaches and
Joseph yes and just those like subtle
eye moments where we're just like both
kind of judging each other you know what
I mean it was really fun he brought up
your eyes he said just what we'd be in a
scene and there was so many background
artists and I would always find him and
just be like and he would do the same so
we creeped each other out yeah okay
this you are a social media icon and and
this show kind of yeah so tell me about
your take on social media there were a
lot of elements in the script where I
was like okay done that before
hope no one's done that before you know
because you are using it now to find out
about people find out about different
things and googling different people and
going on their instagrams sometimes you
know you haven't caught up with them in
person and so long but you know
everything that they've been up to and I
think that's the same with the show but
almost borderlines of like when does
that become too much when does it become
obsessive and stalkerish because further
there's a few moments in you know the
episode where you're like oh is that
romantic and you kind of are confused
with if he's being sweet or if he's
taking it too far and that's sort of the
question throughout the season know what
okay pretty little liars
there's talk there's
talk about reunions for all kinds of
shows might there be a reunion for
Pretty Little Liars
you know Never Say Never I think for
right now they have the perfectionist
which I'm so excited to see um so I'm
curious to see how that is gonna go and
then you never know might you make an
appearance you never know haha that's
the answer that I said for seven years
you know and they'd be like what's gonna
have a next thing I'm like you never
know are you gonna be around you never
know and that's kind of my answer even
don't know so never say never you never
know well and for you
Congrats on a second season thank you so
awesome shooting in LA now that is where
I heard that that's gonna be the next
location so he's gonna be taking on LA
I'm curious to see the new characters I
would be jumping on board I am curious I
mean I watch like Sheikh Asians and if
are you gonna change how you do things
after appearing on this show even I
think that as long as you know I try and
be cautious sometimes I don't want to
post in real time always where I'm at
but even with you know traveling and
that kind of stuff yeah I do bank a lot
of photos and a lot of different videos
that I do post at a later time that's
sort of how I do things
for the most part well what can you why
this project after pretty little liars
why do I love the character I love that
it was a 180 from the character that I
played for seven years you know and
getting to play peach was just fun and
the concept of the show and it's
shooting in New York it just had all
these really wonderful elements to it
that I was really excited to be a part
of and I love this look right now it's
kind of visit peach it's kind of peach I
mean look at these like snake earrings
and then of course Elizabeth Mayo is
like twirling in a flower dress I'm like
yeah that that's our characters -
absolutely I mean the style
yeah for sure I brought a lot of my
wardrobe to New York and got to really
play around with a stylist for the show
to create her look and her image and her
vibe so that was really fun to have
that I hope this is okay that texted a
friend of ours and asked if I should ask
anything in particular
okay no no not at all what was that he
said ask if she's in love oh that's so
fun oh my gosh am I in love every day of
my life I think if one thing you know
people would use to describe it be
passionate and in love just for
everything so a hundred percent I'm
definitely in love I love that mm-hmm oh
I want to ask were you a fan of Gossip
Girl oh absolutely yeah I grew up
watching that show and that you know was
one of the reasons why it's been on my
bucket list to shoot in New York because
of Gossip Girl and then I just got a
bonus with a cherry on top of shooting
with Penn so it was amazing yeah and
John I mean yeah hello full house it's
crazy but he still looks the same as as
I remember him like 20 years ago
it's kind of crazy so what can you tease
us with next season next season I mean
just even a different location cuz in
itself New York and the cityscape played
a character for season one so it's gonna
be really fun to see you know in
Hollywood what the different elements
are gonna bring if it's gonna make it
easier or not and it's gonna be very
very fun to see the new characters come
into this show also it has strong women
yeah how do you play such a strong women
what kind of message do you want the
audience cuz you know it's gonna be
girls watching mm-hmm
what kind of message do you want you to
send to them I mean I think me and the
character that Elizabeth plays are very
strong women you know and I love the
relationship that they have with each
other and I think that's what I love too
about Pretty Little Liars was the fact
that all those girls had such a strong
bond with one another and although at
times sometimes peach doesn't come
across as the sweetest she does really
care for back immensely and you do see
that so I love the fact that their
relationship is very strong